Je pense que j'aimerais avoir tes cheveux c'est
ta couleur naturelle tellement belle
tu ne penses pas qu'elle est juste parfaite
c'est que son vrai nez ouais la vie est
si
injuste tu viens de sortir de l'atelier de carrosserie
elle est encore un peu sensible  tu as fait du
travail tu dis que comme si c'était une mauvaise
chose
ma chérie les plastiques sont juste un bon toilettage
imaginez passer un an sans
vous brosser les dents Je vais chez ce gars à Beverly
Hills et dr.  Andrew elle est amoureuse de
lui bien sûr je l'aime regarde moi
il m'appelle la femme bionique a envoyé un
compliment
j'entends que tes parents sont morts ça doit
être vraiment dur pour toi tu as une autre
famille non personne du tout tu dois avoir un
petit ami
tout ce qu'elle veut vraiment savoir c'est qui
tu es [ __ ]
désolé c'est Jesse
où est ta carte
Je n'en ai pas encore Jesse est nouveau en ville
mais elle vient d'être signée par Roberta
Hoffman comment olie 19 pouvez-vous gérer mon
expérience pas vraiment d'accord allons  voir la
marche cher
toi